Why do I know I discussed
religious fundamentalism
more often and more in depth.
Many people consider you a religious
apologist as a consequence.
Well,
it's okay if people considered
me a religious apologist.
I am a religious apologist.
So an apologist is someone who
makes an argument for something.
And I'm constantly making arguments
for a religious perspective on life or
religious orientation towards life.
Uh,
uh,
an orientation that's centered in,
in meaning,
I know orientation that's centered in
desire for all things to thrive in so far
is that it's possible desire for people
to speak the truth and act out the truth
and act responsibility,
act responsibly,
and all of that.
And I think that there's some something
transcendently necessary about all of
that.
And I think it is the antidote to hell.
So that that makes me
a religious apologist.
The fundamentalists,
I dunno.
Which fundamentalists you mean if you
mean the Christian fundamentalists?
Well,
I understand where they're coming from.
You know,
I think the Christian
Christianity is an ethical
framework above all else.
And it's predicated in a story about
the way the world is constituted and,
and the story provides the foundation
for that ethic and the ethic unites the
community and gives people direction.
This is a big deal.
Now,
if the story is challenged,
if the foundational stories challenged,
which is certainly what happened as a
consequence of the rise of empirical
science,
then the foundation for
the ethic starts to,
okay,
starts to shake and tremble.
And that threatens the ethic.
But the ethic is what holds people
together and gives them direction.
So you can't just lose the ethic.
So the fundamentalist Christians are all
short circuited because they know that
there's something to the ethic and they
understand that the foundation has been
shaken,
but they don't know what to do about it.
So they insist that the
foundation has not been shaken.
And I understand that.
So I think the way out of
that is to understand that
the truth that govern ethics and the
truths that govern the description of the
world as a material
place are not the same.
They're not,
they're not.
They're not of the same kind.
Um,
how they're related.
I'm not exactly sure,
but there's no simple
one to one relationships.
You can't describe the world and then
immediately extract out in ethic.
It's partly because there are just
too many ways of describing the world.
So,
and this is the,
that the fundamental point of difference
as far as I can tell between Sam Harris
and I and hopefully what
we'll discuss in the summer.
So,
so that's the Christian fundamentalists
and I don't really see that they're a
particularly threatening
group as far as I can tell.
I mean there are certainly not in
the ascendance by any stretch of the
imagination.
Um,
they're not involved in any particularly
reprehensible political behavior unless
you count conservatism.
And it is by no means obvious that
they're even holding their ground in the
culture war.
So I'm not very worried about them.
Um,
Islamic fundamentalism,
that's a whole different story.
But I don't know enough about
it to discuss it intelligently.
I don't understand Islam.
It,
it,
I'm concerned about.
It's,
what would you call compatibility with,
with the Democratic West?
It isn't obvious to me that there
are medium to high functioning Muslim
democracies.
I suppose turkeys the closest one,
but Turkey's pretty soon,
pretty shaky at the moment.
I think that the failure to
separate church and state,
or even if we don't call it a failure,
the fact that church and state hasn't
been technically separated in Islam makes
it difficult to understand how it's
possible for Islam and modern western
democratic traditions to coexist.
I don't know how that can be,
that gap can be bridged.
Um,
you could say,
well with goodwill and let's,
let's hope that's the case.
Um,
that doesn't mean I don't think that
Muslims can live in a modern western
democracy.
I mean there are many,
many kinds of Muslims just like there
are many kinds of Jews and Christians.
And so,
and then there's the problem
of the current proclivity
of the extreme end of the
Muslim fundamentalist world to become,
to be very violent in very many ways.
And so,
you know what,
I'm not a great admirer of
the Saudis to say the least.
I don't appreciate their brand of,
of Wahhabi Islam.
And I don't appreciate their exports of
that view with their petro dollars to
the rest of the world.
So
I guess that's what I have
to say about fundamentalists.
Hello,
Dr. Peterson.
I've been trying to
listen to my conscience,
but I can't tell the
difference between fear,
willful blindness or genuine conscience.
Well,
the first thing I would say about that
is it is quite clear that you are in fact
to listen to your conscience because
that's probably the first thing that you
discover.
So that's a really good question.
Okay.
Fear.
Well,
here's the test and you don't
want to do this stupidly.
If you think that you should do something
and you think that the reason you
might not be doing it is
because you're afraid,
then you should do it.
Okay?
So that way you can find out if it's fear.
You know,
I think your question is,
well,
how do I know my conscience isn't
just masquerading as fierce saying,
well,
you shouldn't do that,
but it's rationalizing the real issue,
which is you're afraid of doing that.
Now,
see,
here's a reason that you
want to tell the truth.
And I parked,
I kind of figured this out when I was
looking deeply into the Pinocchio Story.
You know,
in Pinocchio as Pinocchio
strives to become real,
he,
he has a conscience to guide him,
but it's jimminy cricket,
this insect.
But Jimmy hasn't really
a very good conscience.
He's a bit dogmatic to begin with.
Dogmatic and inexperienced.
And so it's,
it's not like the conscience
is an unerring guide.
It's like a partner in discovery.
And as you move forward in your life
and you consult your conscience and you
listen to it,
then it gets smarter and so to you.
But there's a code of their,
and this is why I've suggested part
of the reason why I've suggested so
frequently in my lectures and in
my book that people try not to lie.
You see,
there are many systems,
you have many systems within,
let's say,
that guide you.
And one of those is your
capacity for rational thought.
And then you have a variety of emotional
systems and motivational systems and
internal dramas and uh,
intuitions and bodily sensations
like lots and lots of and senses,
lots of systems that are guiding you.
And many of them operate,
you might say,
unconsciously,
autonomously,
instinctively,
implicitly,
all of that.
Now you PR nonetheless,
you programmed them like
you feed them content,
let's say just like you
feed your body nourishment,
you feed them content and a lot of the
content that you feed them pertains
directly to your voluntary thoughts
and speech and your actions.
And then if you
pathologize those by lying.
So if you say things that you know not
to be true or you don't say things that
you know to be true when you need to,
which is more common.
And if you act in ways that you
consider that act in ways you considered
reprehensible,
then you pathologize all of those
autonomous systems that guide you.
It's like you're programming them badly,
you're building an AI system
inside yourself really in,
in,
in some sense that is what
you're doing that has very bad,
it's very bad training data.
And so the output it
produces will be well,
won't guide you properly.
And so you don't want to
pathologize your guidance systems.
It's a really bad idea.
So that's why you have to not lie.
And maybe that's also why you
have to say what you have to say.
And you have to say it clearly as well.
And you have to learn how to do that.
So that's one of the ways of getting
your conscience straightened out.
And then you have to have a
dialogue with your conscience.
And you might ask,
it's like,
okay,
well what should I do?
Or what should,
should I do this or should I not do this?
So let's say you're thinking,
should I not do this?
In the case of a temptation,
maybe you have a chance to
develop a new relationship.
You know,
and you're,
you're excited about it and apprehensive
about it and afraid of it and you don't
know how to sort out all those feelings.
And the first thing is you really
have to want to sort them out.
That's why you have to orient yourself
to something that's a genuine up.
You know that the star above the horizon,
you have to really want things to be
straight and you have to have thought that
through.
And you have to know what it means
for things not to be straight.
And really what it means is that you're
headed for hell in one way or another.
And if you understand that it's enough,
maybe it's enough to scare you straight,
you really got to think that through.
Then you've got to think about how much
better it would be if you aimed up.
And that really has to kind
of permeate your whole being.
And so then you're oriented that way.
You're oriented to dop and you're
deciding that it's okay to try to tell the
truth and then you can start to rely
on this dialogue with your conscience.
But both of you have to learn and you're
going to make mistakes along the way.
You know that's okay.
You can say,
well,
I'm going to try this without
being certain that it's right.
You can even say,
I'm going to say this without
being certain that it's correct.
Like if you're arguing with your
wife or your husband or your,
or your sister,
your father,
and you have an idea about
what might be going on,
you can say,
look,
here's my idea about what's going on.
Um,
who knows what that idea
might be contaminated with,
like maybe I'm putting it forward just
because I'm too proud or arrogant or
angry or fearful or whatever.
That's possible.
Let's see if we can figure that out.
But you can offer it
tentatively and both have added.
That's what you do if it's a hypothesis,
right?
You both have at it and see if
it's an idea that's worthy of,
of keeping you do that with your
conscience and then you were move forward.
There's a,
there's a technique in behavioral
psychology called psychotherapy called
collaborative empiricism.
So let's say that we,
you and I have been sitting down and
we decided that you're going to try
something new this week,
like maybe your agoraphobic and you're
having a hard time in a parking lot.
And so getting out of the car
and going to the grocery store.
So maybe we say,
well,
you know,
to drive to the grocery store and
you're just going to walk halfway to the
halfway from your car to the door.
And that's good enough for like do that
every second day for a week and then
come back and let's talk about it.
So that's collaborative empiricism,
you're running a little experiment,
you think,
well your conscience is
guiding you towards something.
You take a tentative step in that
direction and then you check and see,
well,
you know,
did what I wanted to have
happen ochre as an outcome.
That's the crucial question and that's
the crucial question for behavioral
truth,
right?
That's the pragmatic perspective.
Did what I want to have happen happen
as a consequence of my framework of
interpretation and my action.
If the answer is yes,
then I have not invalidated it.
Right?
That's,
that's the pragmatic philosophy
in a nutshell and it's,
it's very,
very smart.
So you have a dialogue with
your conscience that never ends,
and hopefully it gets
wiser and you get wiser.
And
that's the dialogue that young talked
about between the conscious and the
unconscious,
between your,
your fantasy life,
say the life that sort of underneath
you as a conscious being like you're the
life that's part of your
biological platform,
the biological platform that somehow
miraculously gives rise to your
consciousness.
If a dialogue with that,
we're always in dialogue.
We're always in dialogue,
right,
with everything.
So
pursue that.